[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to hear in one evening the
clarinet played by many different people
in many different ways we're hearing it
in a jazz setting we're hearing it in an
orchestral setting and I think that gave
a nice opportunity for the audience to
experience the full breadth of this
instrument
[Music]
third grade is where you were the
earliest age you could join the band
program and so every year they would
show the beginning third graders and
have a presentation where the fourth and
fifth graders they would go and play
their instruments on stage and the third
graders in the audience and then it was
trying to convince them to join the band
and to pick an instrument and so I kinda
wanted to play saxophone
because a little bit my dad's influence
that was a favorite instrument but the
clarinet wasn't like a lot smaller and
like I realized that it could fit in my
backpack and I would have to lug around
like that
[Music]
I saw this concert advertised and then I
saw if you bring your own instrument you
can play along and three
the fact that we're inviting Clara
NIST's from around town to come and
actually play with us that's kind of
unprecedented
[Music]
I've been learning new notes throughout
the rehearsals
[Music]
[Applause]
the rhythm to this piece changes so
often that it's really fun to play
[Music]
to be able to play with these great
clarinetists that's just you know once
in a lifetime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]